salut à tous cette vidéo est sponsorisée
par norvpn nor VPN c'est le meilleur VPN
du marché c'est tout d'abord
l'abonnement basique qui te permet de
chiffrer tes donné de changer ton adress
IP pour par exemple regarder les
dernières sorties sur le catalogue US de
disd plus avant leur sortie en France ou
encore de bénéficier de réduction comme
par exemple l'abonnement crunchy roll
qui est moins cher depuis une IP turque
et si vous voulez même un vrai argument
cette fois-ci si vous regardez YouTube
depuis une IP en Albanie vous n'aurez
pas de
pub j'aurais pas dû dire ça
l'abonnement essentiel avec en plus la
protection antimmenace qui bloque les
sites de fishing qui analyse les
fichiers que vous téléchargez et détecte
les applications à risque et ce n'est
pas
tout on on va aller chercher du alors
chérie tu manges comme une grosse
dégueulasse oh non la pub qu'est-ce qui
va se passer pendant les 7 prochaines
secondes je vais tout
rater on a tous connu ça et bien c'est
terminé grâce à norvpn qui supprime les
publicités intrusives sur twitch
qu'est-ce que vous faites dans la
chambre de notre
fille n est pour rien c'est
norvpn et enfin l'abonnement ultime qui
vous permet d'accéder en plus aux autres
produits de North security avec nor pass
le gestionnaire de mot de passe sécurisé
et norlocker un Cloud de 1 chiffré de
bout en bout et Norman sniper qui vous
protégera de tout le reste j'adore
merci norvpn téléchargez norvpn en
passant par le lien en description et
utiliseer jusqu'à 10 appareils en
simultané profitez de 4 mois
d'abonnement supplémentaires sur les
abonnements nvpn de 2 ans satisfait ou
remboursés sur les 30 premiers
[Musique]
jours le Big Bang
l'univers les atomes qui s'agrègent la
poussière stellaire
au fil de milliards d'années des nuages
cosmiques émergent lentement et densent
sur la voûte céleste de notre Voie
[Musique]
Lactée la croûte terrestre se solidifie
peu à peu avant de se refroidir le
bombardement cosmique incessant de
Météor donne naissance aux océans et
soudain une étincelle la vie est là
grouillante bordante elle conquierent
l'ensemble de notre terre et le temps le
temps défile des créatures majestueus
apparaissent et disparaissent et leur
reste se dépos au fond de l'océan
résidus fossiles de matière organique
année après année siècle après siècle la
lente décomposition crée une matière
appelée
pétrole l'or noir que le cucux clan
appelait l'or or blanc est extrait et
par divers procédés chimiques transformé
en polymère pour donner naissance à un
matériaux appelé
plasticum le plastique
polyéthylène modelé façonné recréé pour
atterrir dans les mains de nos enfants
sous la forme d'un jouet de merde et
l'innocente Caroline ne sait pas qu'en
réalité elle joue avec un cadavre de
tricératopse quoi tu n'as pas honte
Caroline rends-moi mon corps offre-moi
une sépulture sauve mon âme
[Musique]
Caroline 1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
GEM et les hologrammes la dernière fois
qu'on en a parlé c'était il y a 9 ans
wou pour vous rafraîchir la mémoire il
s'agit d'un dessai animé sorti en 80
quelque chose avec un générique beaucoup
trop bien animé par rapport au reste de
la série qui raconte les aventures de
j'ae alias jerica dans la vraie vie et
de sa bande de copines qui trouve une
machine du nom de synergie leur
permettant à l'aide des boucles
d'oreilles de gemme de donner cartte
blanche aux animateurs fous qui
travaillent pour eux le spectacle
[Musique]
commence et qui vivent des petites
aventures où elles affrontent les
missfit groupe
concurrenttion
j voilà sauf que depuis qu'on a fait
cette vidéo il y a 9 ans ben il y a eu
un film j' et les hologrammes avec des
vrais acteurs et
lui bonjour alors déjà pourquoi l'argent
je me dis que c'est peut-être parce
qu'il y a eu Transformers qui a marché
aussi et peut-être GI Jo donc ils se
sont dit qu'ils allaient peut-être
réessayer de faire la même chose avec un
autre jouet des années 80 dans le même
style l'argent et puis un film transf ça
coûte extrêmement cher à animer avec
toutes ces 3D alors imagine si tu
arrives à faire un succès commercial
avec un film sur des ados qui chantent
et qui coûte 30 fois moins cher l'argent
et ben tu touches le jackpot donc
forcément tu peux oui oui oui oui
l'argent dans les années 80 un jour
quelqu'un a eu une idée de génie
ok les pubs c'est génial on le sait tous
mais si on mettait des pubs entre les
pubs alors les pubs se retrouveraient
également entre les pubs et le monde
entier ne deviendrait qu'un serpent de
pub qui se mort la queue
maman et en résumant c'est comme ça qu'
né l'idée de faire des dessins animés
pour vendre des jouets c'est Musclor qui
a commencé en premier et très vite tout
le monde a enchaîné he tortu ninja
masque Jay et les conquérents j Jo W et
bien sûr aussi GEM et les hologrammes
alors allez on avance dans le
temps ok on revient un petit peu dans le
temps fin des années 2000 Transformers a
l'idée de reprendre les vieux jouer des
années 80 pour les transformer en film
chose que muscleor avait déjà essayé de
faire mais on vous racontera ça une
autre fois et dans la foulée c'est
également j Jo qui s'y essaye ainsi
qu'en 2015 jamais les hologrammes trois
licences de chez Hasbro Hasbro qui
détient d'ailleurs sachez-le aussi la
licence Ouija voilà le Ouija c'est une
marque déposée asbro donc ça ne sert à
rien de vous [ __ ] en l'air parce que
le capitalisme vous insupporte sachez
qu'il contrôle déjà l'outr monde donc j
et les hologrammes sortis en 2015 mais
qui avait commencé à être écrit d'après
le réalisateur près de 10 ans avant vous
savez c'est c'est ces gros cacas là où
tu pousses très fort et ta tête devient
tout rouge mais ça veut pas sortir
réalisé par un type du nom de John CHU
qui a aussi fait le film GI Jo 2 et le
documentaire sur Justin Bieber d'un côté
donc un jouet des années 80 et de
l'autre la genèse d'une star d'Internet
fusion des deux j'aimeis les hologrammes
alors est-ce que ce concept peut marcher
et bien un petit jeu pour chez vous à
finir avant la fin de la vidéo he sinon
c'est de la triche voici trois articles
qui parlent du film essayez donc de les
remettre dans l'ordre
le film s'ouvre donc sur sans arrêt en
train de
changer je suis pas vraiment moi-même
sur ma chaîne je suis plein de
personnages alors attendez est-ce que je
me suis trompé de film est-ce que j'ai
peut-être ouvert YouTube par hasard non
non bah non non non c'est bon c'est là
on retrouve alors jerica héroïne du film
qui fait un vlog confessionnel qui va
servir de fils rougge pendant toute la
durée du film on a tous une identité
secrète c'est une version nous-même
créée pour être liké
partagé et suivi bah du coup non c'est
pas secret et d'ailleurs moi jerica
Benton j'aimerais avouer certaines
choses à mon ami
fidèle
Internet vous l'aurez compris donc c'est
clairement un film Jen qui nous vient
d'une époque où on croyait que les
réseaux sociaux pouvaient encore être
une bonne chose et voilà donc les autres
personnages à commencé par la sœur de
jerica Kimberly vous voyez les gens qui
vont sur internet pour partager leur vie
dans les moindres détails et bien en
gros c'est Kimber qui a créé la tendance
attends du coup c'est elle qui a créé le
fait de partager sa vie sur
internet Chana il y a Shana une vraie
fashionista à la créativité plus que
débdé ça ne servira pas dans le film et
a et il y a ja génie à mi-temps rebelle
à pleintemps et ça non plus ça ne
servira pas dans dans le film tout ce
petit monde vit chez tamb béé une femme
qui a recueilli les filles depuis que le
père de jerica et Kim et M est mort il
m'appelait sans diamant brut ou ça
j'aime père malade comme vous pouvez le
voir sur ces extraits où il a clairement
l'air d'être à l'agonie et qui passait
tout son temps à bosser sur un robot du
nom de synergie bref après cette partie
confession vidéo et alors que tout le
monde s'engueule pour une histoire de
fringue t baayé rentre à la maison us
Kimber fais-moi un dos tu es sérieuse t
oui je suis sérieuse un
[Musique]
dos c'est une secte mes créantes chantez
pour Zor car c'est notre
[Musique]
Seigneur bref c'était la manière pas
très subtile du film d'introduire le
fait qu'elles aiment bien faire de la
musique alors s'amuse à se déguiser à
faire des chansons et cetera mais
soudain une lettre arrive la tante
risque de se faire expulser et les
filles si c'était le cas se verrai
séparer les unes des autres mais que
faire bah trouver un travail est-ce que
tout est fichu non parce que en ce
moment chez Burger King jerica est perdu
dans ses pensées rongé par le désespoir
de n'avoir aucune solution et chez McDo
aussi apparemment mais non elle a trouvé
l'illumination la seule solution est
évidemment j'ai quelque chose à vous
annoncer je vais être youtubeuse
[Musique]
JICA dans un moment de mélancolie enfile
donc sa plus belle perruque et
enregistre une petite chanson à la
guitare sèche sans prétention en prenant
le nom de scène de j' elle décide de ne
pas l'loader mais c'est sa sœur
Kimberley qui le fait sans lui demander
et bien sûr les commentaires sont
unanimes
[Musique]
non pardon excusez-moi ça c'est si on
était dans la réalité parce que
évidemment dans le pays des merveille
cette chanson Ma foi médiocre fait le
buzz sur Youtube et là c'est le défilé
de n'importe quoi tu sais que ça a été
écrit par quelqu'un qui sait que les
jeunes ça va sur les réseaux sociaux
mais qui sait pas vraiment comment ça
marche je veux dire le truc est en ligne
depuis moins de 8h et il y a déjà des
plateaux télé de de de réaction qui
commentent la vidéo et tout toute la
toile s'en flamme pour cette vidéo
postée par une artiste que l'on ne
connaît que sous le nom de J la vidéo de
J est magique mais elle chante et elle
fait de la guitare mais c'est incroyable
et tout ça en même
temps il combien de vu du coup et tu
portais le collier que j'ai fait 36000
personnes nont pu voir mon collier
36000 vues
waouh mais vous imaginez c'est seulement
33 fois moins que la vidéo du mec qui
pète sur des
[Musique]
chiens après c'est une très bonne vidéo
bref ça c'est vraiment un truc qui est
énervant dans ce film c'est cette
illusion que le monde est juste que la
sincérité ça paye et que donc sous
prétexte qu'elle est un peu gentille et
qu'elle a une cause juste alors ben ça
va forcément marcher alors que spoil ça
peut être aussi de la merde sincère
évidment c'est le succès absolu on lui
propose instantanément trois concerts à
Los Angeles écoutez ça er vient de
proposer à de faire conerts à Los
Angeles 36000 vues tu rends compte
monsieur il y a un type qui a fait une
vidéo où il pète sur des gâteaux il a
fait 50000 vues en 24 he programmez-le
tout de
suite devant ce succès fulgurant jerica
se pose instantanément des questions sur
l'avenir ils veulent une personne qui
qui n'existe même
pasas c'est bon calme-toi tu as même pas
fait une répétition tu es personne pour
l'instant si je monte sur scène ils ne
verront pas c'est eu Jim il veront juste
une gamine qui devrait plutôt chanter
sous la douche au lieu de rêver de
gloire tu fais 6000 fois moins de vues
qu'une vidéo de bruit
blanc après aussi une très bonne vidéo
quand même il s'est pas fait colou
depuis si mais j'ai j'ai vu sa vidéo
d'explication et et franchement je lui
pardonne jerica décide donc de répondre
à l'offre qu'elle a vu sur le net et
négocie avec un label de musique nommé
Starlight industrie l'offre n'étant que
pour elle à la base ce qui a du sens vu
que c'est la seule à apparaître sur la
fameuse vidéo sur Internet jerica fait
le forcing pour placer ses amis et
Starlight industrie accepte ce qui est
quand même super risqué parce que cet
énorme label de disque vient d'accepter
de signer des filles qu'elle n'a jamais
vu ni entendu et maintenant tout de
suite sans plus attendre on retrouve et
les
hologram le lendemain la du nom de er
rayond arrive chez les filles pour les
emmener à Los Angeles et mesdemoiselle
voici Rio notre stagiaire il est là pour
s'occuper de vous pendant votre séjour
alors n'hésitez pas oh tiens sera la
romance du film bref elles sont donc là
toutes pour se relooker
swag training montage qu'on a déjà vu
1000 fois dans 1000 films différents
Erika en profite au passage pour prendre
les boucles d'oreilles de GEM en forme
d'étoile et les met dans un coffre parce
qu'elle trouve ça un petit peu moche on
va les mettre à l'abri ne t'en fait pas
alors c formtion servira pour plus tard
et c'est débile parce que elle a aucune
idée de ce que c'est elle a aucune
raison de lui prendre comme ça elle
aurait juste pu lui dire ben tes boucles
d'oreille ell sont moches mais est dans
ta poche les filles se relookent et les
voilà emmené dans une villa de Rockstar
pour la nuit quand
[Musique]
soudainement synergie a prè vie plan
d'éradication des humains
activés sélectionner la race de votre
choix alors synergie hein pour rappelle
dans la série c'est cette espèce de
clavier robot qui fait des hologrammes
de fou et qui transforme tout le dessin
animé en une version un petit peu girly
de gris de lanterne synergie donc
s'active et affiche un plan qui envoie
les filles vers un emplacement situé
dans la jetée de Santa Monica
ouis et ben tu m'étonne que le père il
était pas présent s'il a passé les 10
dernières années de sa vie à construire
un robot du futur juste pour faire une
chasse au trésor donc les filles partent
sur place et sur la jeté de Santa Monica
trouve une énigme à faire ce qui leur
donne encore une autre pièce à ajouter à
la machine ce qui ouvre un autre plan
vers un autre endroit à trouver leur
chaperon les retrouve aussi mais
malheureusement les flics arrivent
également tout le monde plonge alors à
l'eau et ressort quelques mètres plus
loin au bord de
[Musique]
oui alors disons que dans le dessin
animé il effement souvent des passages
musicaux qui sortent un peu nulle part
mais avec des vrais acteurs ça fait
bizarre arrête maintenant attends 5
minutes j'ai appelé les renfor ah ti
synergie c'est du
rap
TS grandmre pr pendant ce tempsl
Starlight industrie annonce qu'elle a
signé à partir de maintenant son compte
Youtube est à Starlight et vous pourrez
uniquement accéder à son contenu via
notre site
internet c'estia en fait et il est donc
temps de faire enfin la première
répétition qui sera aussi d'ailleurs le
premier moment du film où on les entend
vraiment chanter
[Musique]
ensemble oh [ __ ] j'aurais dû écouter
avant après les répétitions nous voilà
donc à l'Open Air club une salle de
spectacle où la révélation d'Internet g
36 vu sur Youtube va se produire ce qui
est encore une fois je rappelle 277 fois
moins de vues que cette vidéo d'écran
rouge sans aucun son on retrouve donc
les filles juste avant le spectacle dans
la voiture le stress monte et ça y est
c'est le grand moment l'heure
d'affronter le public et leurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fans je suis désolé de remettre ça sur
le tapis mais vraiment on n pas vu
le reste du groupe sur la fameuse vidéo
qui buz sur Youtube donc quand ces sœurs
sortent de la voiture le public il
devrait être en mode c'est
qui regardez derrière c'est le mec qui
pète sur des
[Applaudissements]
chiens et le concert commence alors je
vais pas mettre les chansons en entier
pour des questions de droit ni commenter
la musique d'ailleurs on aime ou on
aaime pas mais bon en bref c'est du Hana
Montana et en fait quand on y réfléchit
Hana Montana c'est déjà un peu j'aamais
les hologrphes je veux dire une meuf qui
aime bien chanter qui est ado qui a deux
identités c'est déjà complètement
j'aimis les hologrames le concert
évidemment se termine après une seule
chanson donc début 20h fin 20h7 avec en
plus une coupure de courant au milieu
meublé en catastrophe mais ça va les fes
on l'air content céit le meilleur
concert de ma vie et mon premier aussi
mais au moins l'avantage de ce concert
c'est qu'ells ont pu trouver une autre
pièce du robot à
compléter alors papa où est-ce que tu
veux en
venir père tu entends ma voix ne
reconstruis surtout pas ce robot il va
détruire l'humanité toute entière
écoutemoi pendant ce temps-là t Bailey
est en galère de pognon et risque de se
retrouver à la rue ah si seulement on
avait quelque chose d'unique qu'on
pouvait vendre ou utiliser papa est-ce
que j'ai une âme papa réfléchi jerica
demande une avance sur salaire mais le
label n'accepte qu'à la condition
qu'elle signe un contrat solo
abandonnant de fait ses amis jerica
accepte et évidemment trahison disgrâce
c'est le drame car elle la prennent J
juste avant de monter sur scène ouais
alors il y avait quand même beaucoup
d'autres moments plus propices pour
annoncer ça ok les filles vous êtes
prêtes maquillage micro
et vous êtes viré donc chanson pleine de
remords sur scène évidemment on se
regarde dans des miroirs brisés on jette
des trucs de la table quel drama et
d'ailleurs je viens de réaliser mais le
public il s'en fout de tout en fait
premier concert il y a trois meufs
inconnues qui sortent de la voiture et
tout le monde est en folie deè concert
il manque membres du groupe par rapport
au concert d'avant et tout le monde est
en folie c'est bon tu' ce que tu veux
[Musique]
là ce
j'ai la journé
toutç bonjour C'est Deram c'est
complètement
Mo bonjour
ckck bref après son concert jerica a de
façon mélancolique dans les rues de Los
Angeles histoire de se remémorer ses
souvenirs d'enfance elle se décide à
aller traîner du côté de l'ancienne
maison de son père et oh qui voilà c'est
Kimberley sa sœur qui arrive là par
hasard pourquoi pas hein et oh là qui
voilà c'est les autres membres du groupe
qui sont aussi là par hasard bah
d'accord oh là qui voilà c'est le Love
interrestre ok allez oh là qui voilà
c'est l'inspecteur Gadget
ou je fatigue un peu parce que à ce
niveaaulà de coïncidence c'est qu'ils
ont un cerveau de ruche parce que Los
Angeles c'est grand un peu allez petite
discussion entre sœurs un câin et hop on
est toutes rabiboché en moins de 3
minutes pas le temps d'expliquer les
personnages se disent alors qu'il faut
absolument récupérer les boucles
d'oreilles rose de J aime parce que
c'est la clé tout ça parce qu'il y avait
une étoile gravée sur le béton devant
l'ancienne maison du Père les boucles
d'oreilles sers-toi de ce qu'on t'a
donné c'est sûrement la dernière pièce
de synergie ouais ok ouais ça suffit
comme explication visiblement et ben
heureusement que personne n'est venu
graver une [ __ ] à côté plus tard c'est
pourtant
évident c'est ça la
clé le gag suivant a été annulé pour
cause de grosses [ __ ] boucles d'oreille
qui je rappelle sont dans un coffre fort
chez Starlight industrie les filles vont
donc s'infiltrer dans les bureaux de
Starlight industry pour les récupérer et
toute cette scène ne sert à rien he je
tiens le préciser quand même parce que
les boucles d'oreilles elles pourrai
juste attendre le lendemain aller à
Starlight industry et dire B s'il vous
plaît elles sont à moi je voudrais les
récupérer et il y aurait aucun souci
parce que Erika la patronne du label
aussi méchante soit-elle elle n'a aucune
raison de lui refuser elle n'a aucune
idée de l'existence de synergie elle n'a
aucune idée de la fonction des boucles
d'oreilles donc elle n'a aucune raison
de lui refuser tout cette scène est
inutile c'est écrit avec le qul pendant
10 ans un cul épuisé et en plus d'être
inutile ils se sont dit on va aussi
rendre ça insupportable donc toute la
scène d'infiltration est entrecoupée de
clips vidéo de mecs sur Youtube qui font
du
freestyle c'est horrible fouillez toutes
les pièces de cet étage
je sais qu'ils sont
là
c'estpect de côté nord et toi côté sud
ils sont dans le couloir comment ils ont
qu'on était là non non ben en fait vous
savez quoi fallait y aller à fond mon
[Musique]
bureau qu'est-ce que tu fais les filles
réussissent à s'infiltrer sans problème
dans les locaux aidé par l'incroyable
stupidité des
[Applaudissements]
gardes oh je l'adore
venez voir c'est
l'écureuil je peux pas faire de blagues
là-dessus je peux pas rendre ça plus
stupide le film me vole mon travail
attendez une seconde c'est une vraie
forteresse il y a des vigiles partout
vous avez aucune chance de rentrer c'est
l'écureil et elle trouve enfin les
boucles d'oreilles de GEM ainsi qu'un
testament qui donne les pleins pouvoirs
de la société à Rio le fils de la
productrice dans un coffre ultra
sécurisé
avant de sortir du bâtiment au nez et à
la barbe des gardes de sécurité là c'est
officiel on a été repéré tu as des idées
ouais ouis c'est parfaitement normal
d'avoir ce genre d'alarme dans un
bâtiment de label de disque ce qui leur
permet de ramener les boucles d'oreilles
à la maison et donc de compléter le
robot synergy pour enfin trouver le
secret qu'il contenait à savoir une
lettre Postume du Père pour sa fille
quand j'ai découvert qu'il me
restait si peu de temps à vivre j'ai
suis qu'il fallait que je trouve un
moyen
de d'essayer de te transmettre des
valeurs importantes à mes yeux tu vas
voir tu tu vas croire toute ta vie que
je suis un mauvais père mais quand tu
vas retrouver tous les indices et
reconstruire le robot du futur que j'ai
mis 10 ans à faire au lieu de passer du
temps avec toi là ben tu vas voir que je
t'aimis un peu quand même je t'aime
cherica moi aussi je
[Musique]
t'aime
émouvant attends pas une sœur c'est dur
de laisser sa fille grandir sa fille
unique tu es mon trésor au singulier ma
plus grande création ma
gème ça
et mon robot
évidemment
synergie ma seconde plus grande création
mais bien sûr j'allais pas finir comme
ça tu pensais tout de même pas que
j'allais t'oublier
gratouille ma petite boule de poil
j'aimerais jamais personne autant que
toi personne enfin personne à part Kim
ah là là Kim Kim
jangun mon grand leader incompris mon
petit boun je sais que tout ce que tu
faisais c'était pour le bien de ton
peuple tu es juste arrivais trop tôt
c'est tout les gens n'était pas prêt
alors come on dit en coréen chamé
c'était quand même beaucoup d'effort la
création de ce robot juste pour faire un
message parce que ça marchait aussi avec
une VHS et une caméra caméra et VHS qui
sont dans le film d'ailleurs et on passe
à la scène suivante où jerryica résout
sa crise d'identité et avoue au monde
entier qu'elle s'appelle jerica et non
pas Jam dans son vlog et tout le monde
s'en fout mais tant pis allez le film
est presque fini donc les filles
décident de partir pour leur deuxè et
dernier concerts quelle carrière les
amis Erik la patronne du label arrive et
on a donc la confrontation finale avec
non non c'est pour me tuer je vous jure
ah c'est auudelà de mes forces non allez
vas-y allez vas-y c'est bon allez h
Erika se fait donc remplacer par son
fils avec l' du fameux testament qu'ils
avaient trouvé et voilà donc le dernier
concert et attention vous voulez
l'origine story du nom vous voulez le
l'explication de j'ime et les
hologrammes non
rioce journaliste chez rollingone
je crois qu'on peut dire que c'est
magique ce qui se passe ce soir je
voudrais que les quatre filles fassent
notre couve comment elles vont se faire
appeler je pensais à J et les hologramm
sérieusement comment elles vont se faire
appeler je pensais à et la veilleuse de
nuit amazone ou ça sonne pas mal et on
conclut par un final l'art moyen
entrecoupé de témoignag YouTube de gens
qui ont aimé je savais pas qui c'était
mais cette fille avec ses cheveux roses
et ses étoiles aux oreilles j'ai dit
waouh ces filles elles sont trop
mortelles c'est des killeuses elles
m'ont tout simplement beaucoup apporté
alors j'ai du mal à chanter et j'avoue
que je danse pas très bien mais en
résumé grâce à elle j'ai compris que
j'avais le droit d'être comme je voulais
sans avoir peur du regard des autres je
vais t'enculer je vais te briser tes os
je vais te boire ton sang et fin du film
bravo vous avez survécu la scène
postcédit nous tisera l'arrivée des Miss
fit un groupe connu du dessin animé même
si si en vrai bon on dirait davantage
que Erik est parti acheter de l'héroïne
au prostitué du coin et ce film
évidemment a été un bid total puisqu'il
a coûté 5 millions ce qui est très
faible et a quand même réussi l'exploit
de ne rapporter que 2,3 millions au
niveau planétaire ce qui est 53 fois
moins que le film du mec qui pète sur
des chiens bilan en terme de scénario il
y a des incohérences intolérables c'est
mal réalisé et c'est bourré de cache
misère et de fausses idées de
réalisation comme ce lien avec Youtube
et avec l'univers des réseaux sociaux
alors que ça sert juste de cache misère
pour masquer une absence de budget et
d'ailleurs un truc horrible dont j'ai
absolument pas parlé c'est vous savez
tous les témoignages Youtube de gens qui
disent qu'ils aiment Jam là que vous
avez vu plutôt et bien il s'agissait en
fait d'une campagne marketing du film
qui demandait aux gens de dire face
caméra à quel point ils aimaient le
dessai animé GEM et les hologrammes
témoignages qui ont ensuite été édités
en postp pour faire croire que ces mêmes
gens parlaient du film J un film que
aucun de ces gens-là n'avait encore vu
et qui clairement n'a rien à voir avec
le dessin animé de leur enfance qu'ils
aimaient tant mais c'est pas grave
allez-y continuez à nous faire des films
moralisateurs sur les vilaines société
de production capitaliste qui viennent
voler les gentils groupes de musique
mais après peut-être que j'ai tort
peut-être que le film a raison peut-être
que c'est vrai que si on est gentil dans
la vie et bien le karma nous récompense
et et que le succès est garanti vous
savez quoi allez
[Musique]
qui sait qui a fait caca dans La
Bruyère qui sa qui a fait caca dans La
Bruyère je l'URIS quitte à faire le tour
de la terre entière celui qui a fait
caca dans La
Bruyère qui c'est qui s torché dans les
rideaux qui sa qui ch dans les
rideau 7 heure de cette crevure je vais
lui briser tous les au celui qui s'est
torché dans les
rideaux à vous